today's panel presentation harnessing
novel crispr systems for transcriptome
engineering
this presentation is part of the fourth
annual crispr virtual event
i am antonina salcido of lab roots and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
now let's get started
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you first to participate by
communicating with other attendees
using our new live chat feature during
the presentation
you can find the live chat located at
the right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
i now present today's speakers dr omar
abudeja and dr jonathan gutenberg both
fellows at mcgovern institute for brain
research at mit
for a complete biography on our seekers
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen
dr omar abudaya you may now begin your
presentation so yeah thanks for having
uh jonathan and myself today to speak
about some of the research from our lab
at mit um i'm going to give the first
half of our talk on harnessing novel
sister systems for um sort of in vitro
applications such as diagnostics for
healthcare and then i'll pass it on to
jonathan who'll go into a lot of our new
crispr enzymes and their applications
for rna-based therapeutics including a
paper we just published um in nature on
cast 711 the newest sort of rna
targeting effector in the toolbox
so
i'll go ahead and jump in
so you know a lot of our motivation for
our work comes from
the greater understanding we have of
human biology so you know of course
there's more genomes or sequence we're
understanding that there are more and
more
uh genetic uh differences that can be
harmful or beneficial in both uh you
know healthcare and beyond you know
agriculture climate change energy and
even uh more more so
the big need as we understand that
genetic variants can have effects um on
almost you know every aspect of our
lives is that we need tools to probe
these organs understand how they
function and then install the ones that
we want to treat disease or for other
functions and so
uh you know to make a search function
for both not just the human genome but
even for cells and engineering cells
and beyond we really search sort of the
natural world and so you know we spent a
long time mining prokaryotic genomes and
bacterial genomes sifting through
metagenomes to really find new types of
enzymes and tools we can leverage for
biotechnology
and of course there's a rich history
for doing this of course you know
there's so many enzymes out there that
have been used for molecular cloning
like restriction enzymes fluorescent
proteins uh viruses for delivering genes
to cells and of course gene editing and
gene therapy um so
you know in the crystal world we have
spent a lot of time with cast nine and
more recently cpf1 and cash 12s that are
useful for dna
uh editing but
you know they're really only a small
slice of the whole sort of picture
and so you know there's a huge diversity
of other crispr enzymes and so you know
we've spent the past many years sort of
mining these crispr systems and using
signatures of conserved genes that occur
around these systems like cass one cast
2 or even crisper arrays to basically
expand our understanding of crispr
systems and using these pipelines that
basically look for seeds of signatures
or crispr systems and then find new
proteins around these seeds we've
identified many candidates
of new systems and so examples of these
new systems such as the type 5 cast 12s
the type 6 test13s or c2c2 is shown here
and even more recently the cast 711s
which fall in the type 3 world of crispr
systems
which jonathan will dive more into in
his part of the talk
so
uh
basically you know one of the big things
we spent our time on are characterizing
these rna targeting crispr systems and
so cast 13 is one of them
specifically castor dna was kind of the
first one that we found and
what's unique about cas13 is that we
found that it actually can target
nucleic acid much like casting but
instead of targeting dna it targets rna
and when it binds its rna viral genome
it'll cleave but it won't just make a
precise cut like cas9 it actually makes
many cuts
eventually degrading the viral genome
and actually cleaving even non-targeted
nucleic acids they'll just turn on and
cleave anything in the cell
this promiscuous activity um is
interesting um and how we first sort of
uncovered it was looking in test tubes
as the function of the enzyme what we
found
is
we could label these collateral rnas
these green ones that are not targeted
by the crispr rna for the fluorophore
and when we spike in the targeted rna as
shown here in black it activates the
cas13 you get cleavage of the black rna
but you also get cleavage of these green
rnas
and so we thought when we saw this you
know this would not be great to put in a
cell because it will probably would
activate and chew up many transcripts
and and probably turn off genes that you
may not want turned off and maybe
potentially even kill the cell we found
it actually could stall bacterial
bacterial cells and kill bacterial cells
so
we thought this might not be good for
our therapeutics but what we did realize
is the function of you know cleaving
something that's fluorescent in the
presence of a specific rna could be
useful for diagnostics
and so
we thought you know imagine there was
this blue you know rna that you want to
find like you know for example from a
coping 19 and you design guide rnas that
detect this rna and caster team would
bind and activate when those were
present and then cleave reporters that
you know when cleaved release
fluorescence by separating the
fluorophore from a quencher
and so we spent a lot of time developing
diagnostic acids like this and we
actually made them highly sensitive in
an assay called sherlock where we could
couple a pre-amplification of other
nucleic acid up front and so in this
format we basically can take double
stranded dna or rna and actually amplify
it using isothermal amplifications like
rpa or lamp or you know sda
and so on and the amplified dna can be
turned into rna which can then be
detected by cast 13 resulting in
detection
and since then we've actually found that
a lot of other crispr enzymes have this
function so even cast 12s have
collateral activity so you can use class
12s for diagnostics
and we're finding more and more you know
fung recently had this tmpb
paper about ancestral customer systems
that also have collateral so it's you
know a really exciting time in in the
space to realize that we can use crispr
not only for therapeutics but also for
diagnostics
and so over the past few years we've
continued to develop very specific um
applications of these diagnostics and so
uh you know
there's a lot of different areas in
healthcare that could benefit so we've
shown detection of viruses bacteria
uh you know point of care detection on
you know lateral flow strips patient
genotyping from saliva
even cancer detection from you know dna
that's in the blood via kind of
point of care liquid biopsies so
um you know we've been pretty excited
about the broad utility of these
approaches
and uh you know when essentially the
pandemic took off we realized that there
was you know potential that you know
these types of assays like sherlock
could be really beneficial for
copenhagen detection so i want to tell a
little bit about you know our work from
the past year and a half continuing to
improve these chemistries and
diagnostics for uh startup v2 detection
so basically
early on
in the pandemic
uh you know
going back now january 2020 uh
essentially we were getting a lot of
inbound interest from other scientists
and folks who were
uh worried about what was going on in
asia and wanted us to potentially look
into using crispr enzymes to detect
the virus and the big problem was you
know there's obviously qpcr and other
more established nucleic acid detection
methods but they're slow and expensive
and you have other supply constraints
and so there's a big interest in sort of
portable point of care uh technologies
for doing this and as you can just
detect yourself at home in 30 minutes
and so you know
early on we actually uh through sherlock
biosciences
a company we co-founded we actually were
able to get fda authorization of a
crispr-based lab test so this is a test
that has to occur in central
laboratories it's too complex
to run
at home but you know i think it showed
the potential that christopher really
could be used for cover detection and
you know this was just a matter of
months it was repurposed for lab-based
testing we thought what could we do to
make at home or workplace testing
possible and so we actually went back to
the drawing board in january 2020 and
thought well what would it take to you
know take an off-the-shelf you know
pre-amplification chemistry like lamp
and actually have crispr enzymes work in
a single you know
reaction rather than having the multiple
steps i showed before
so we actually found thermophilic
enzymes
from the cast 12 family that actually
could work in the lamp master mix
and what we were able to do
is basically
design a workflow that was incredibly
simple
the idea was that someone could swab
themselves dip that swab in a lysis
buffer uh
that would break open the viral
particles then the nucleic acid would be
blind uh bound by magnetic beads which
you can then pull uh down via magnet
then we replace this lysis buffer with a
master mix uh this is what we call stop
covid and we just incubate at a single
temperature for 30 minutes to an hour
and then we can get real-time detection
by fluorescence or by a lateral flow
strip that we dipped in
and what was cool um
was what was cool about um
that slide or about this workflow um as
shown on this slide was that um
we could really simplify uh the workflow
so uh what we were able to do is
essentially uh take
uh you know a rapid extraction method
whereas other methods developed out
there including our previous protocol
would require purification that would
take 45 minutes and we could combine it
with a single step master mix uh whereas
all the other methods as i mentioned
before have a fluid transfer step as
shown inside the red arrow and so this
simplified format really could be done
in about 30 minutes which was really
great
um and so
uh
we took this chemistry and actually
profiled um almost 400 patient samples
and found that the uh you know test was
actually quantitative so our time to the
threshold the detection was nicely
correlated with the viral load as
measured by qpcr and so it was even
really sensitive down to high ct values
which are really low virus loads in the
35 to 40 range
um
this really this gave us a sensitivity
of about 93 in the specificity of 98
um which is uh we were pretty happy with
for kind of a simple point of care test
and you know going forward we've spent a
lot of time now really trying to get
this to work with all sorts of nasal
samples and making it as robust as
possible and you know our vision for the
future which you know we are working on
is to really
build a device and box around this
chemistry that someone should run at
home something that looks like an apple
homepod almost that you know belongs in
your kitchen or living room but that
actually would allow you to swab
yourself stick you know into a cartridge
that then reads out on this device and
so um i think it's an exciting time for
diagnostics because i think the
chemistries are getting really mature
and you know the crispr chemistry is
just the next step in making very
simplified formats that can be read out
anywhere and now that you know we're
taking the next step of really putting
this on devices we hope that you know
the smart home of the future has really
got you know systems that people can
really test themselves so they wake up
in the middle of night and sick and are
wondering you know do i have a you know
urinary tract infection or something or
is my fever uh due to you know just
or is it you know something more serious
like pneumonia or you know strep throat
or or so on and so um i do think that
futures that future is achievable and
that's what we're working on by making
these chemistry simple and easy and
workable in the point area to care um
sort of format
um
so
you know i think you know going beyond
diagnostics it's obvious as i mentioned
that there's a lot of interest in using
these enzymes in cellular formats for
knocking down rnas editing rnas changing
spicing and regulation of rnas and you
know we've done a little bit of that
with caster keen although casper team of
course has some toxicity concerns uh due
to the collateral effect um so we'll
show some of our work coming up with
cast 13 and also go into a new enzyme
called test 711 that was recently
published that has no collateral and can
be very precise um rna knock down the
modulation so i'll pass it on to
jonathan who will uh dive into a lot of
this exciting work um so thanks so much
thanks omar for covering all the
different things we can do in the
diagnostic side with these new rna
targeting and dna targeting tools
but
as many of you know a lot of the power
of these new crispr enzymes is the
capacity to integrate biology inside of
living cells
and so what can we do with rna targeting
tools well of course there's a lot of
different rna in the cell there's mrna
as well as trna and non-coding rnas so
the capacity to be able to target those
can actually unveil a lot of different
biology
so there are many different things we
could do with these tools
we've actually demonstrated a couple of
things in the potential therapeutics and
basic biology front including the
capacity to use their endogenous
nuclease capacity for rna knockdown as
well as the ability to do base editing
so by fusing different deaminase domains
to these enzymes we can actually be able
to make specific base edits
now we don't have time to cover both of
these today but we'll talk a little bit
about what we can do on the rna
knockdown front using both the cas13
enzymes as well as new enzymes we've
very recently discovered
now you could think it might be very
easy to apply caster t inside mammalian
cells and
to an extent that's correct
so we can actually take cast 13 and put
it in mammalian cells with a crispr rna
targeting a transcript here we use a
ratio metric reporter that has a
gaussian luciferase and a criprodine
luciferase by targeting one of the
luciferase here the gaussia
we can actually measure the ratio
between the two and see the extent of
knock down
and if we do this in hex 293 ft cells we
can actually see that
depending on how we actually
fuse either cytoplasmic or nuclear
localization sequences to the cast of
15a
we can actually get knockdown levels as
good as or
or better than rnai so you can see with
both guides one and guides two with
especially the nuclear caster dna we can
get improved knockdown
and that's not a small feature the
capacity to be able to localize these
enzymes to different compartments
because when targeting things like
non-coding rnas that are
primarily resonant in the nucleus we can
actually be able to target those better
than things like rnai
however we want to be able to look at
the specificity of these systems
so
if you look at the specificity
you can take a targeting guide and a
non-targeting guide and actually be able
to compare using transcript and wide
sequencing the amount of knock down
so if you take
a normal targeting guide against
gaussian luciferase and
we actually plot it here is the rnai
version and you can see across that
middle axis there's a lot of fuzziness
there's a lot of transcripts that are
either up regulated or down regulated
and you however if you take the cash 13a
and overlay it you can actually see it's
much more tight distribution and that
small dot off to the lower right that's
actually the gaussian luciferase being
knocked down so it's a much more precise
enzyme at least in these cells
and this is true for multiple cast 13s
so if we take do the same experiment
with the cast 13b
from
psp
you can see that we actually have a
similar level of specificity
however
even though we did this in heck 293 ft
cells
it doesn't necessarily hold across all
cell lines potentially because as you
remember
these cast 13s as well as the cast 12s
have this collateral activity where when
they're activated
they chew up many different rnas
so
if you actually target in certain cell
lines including u87 glioblastoma cell
lines
you actually see that
and this is done by a different group
but you can actually see that there's a
loss of viability and reduced cell
growth and if you actually run the
ribosomal rna on a gel you see a loss of
integrity
so this really opens up a question
can we actually make new rna targeting
tools to reduce the toxic effects of
these things like collateral and provide
better transcript perturbation methods
and of course we want to go back to the
drawing board which for us is natural
discovery
so
you'll remember that omar kind of
brought up this breakdown of crispr
enzymes coming from class 1 and class 2.
and you recall that the class 2 enzymes
are much more easy to use because
everything is fused together all these
functions come with one single protein
however
the class 1 enzymes also often have many
great functions for both dna and rna
targeting
it's just that because they're not a
single protein
they are harder to express and use in
mammalian cells however
any sort of metric or
framework is always meant to be broken
so you can see that basically these
class 1 systems have multiple proteins
so these type 3 enzymes where all of
these different
parts are concatenated together
so in normal type 3 systems you can see
that there's multiple subunits called
cast 7s as well as sometimes a cas11
subunit
here in these type 3e systems the cast
7s and the cas11 have actually been
concatenated and fused evolutionarily
into a single protein with four cast
seven subunits and one cas11 subunit
this we call cast 711 and we actually in
a recent publication
show that it functions as an rna
targeting enzyme much like the other
type 3 systems
however because a single protein this is
two largely significant findings one
that class one enzymes and class one
systems
don't always have multiple different
proteins and here this actually breaks
that uh terminology
and that
evolutionary uh
classification
secondly
because it can actually function as a
single enzyme we thought that it might
be able to be very useful as an rna
targeting system in mammalian cells
so one interesting note is that type iii
systems while rna targeting lack the
collateral activity of the cast 13
systems and we can actually see that in
both biochemical and e coli based assays
so
if you do a biochemical collateral assay
where we incubate with a
bystander reporter rna that's
fluorescent and a trigger rna you can
see that the only large curve coming up
here is coming from the lwa cas13a and
that the cast 711 has no activity on
that collateral reporter because it has
no collateral activity
secondly if you look for this effects of
this in e coli
when you do targeting with a lda cast
13a you get a reduction of growth so if
you have the rfe targeting guide there
you actually when you're cutting in
these e coli express rfp
you actually don't have a large
reduction of growth with cast 711 you
see no growth effects
so
here we have an enzyme that can actually
function as an rna targeting
system as one protein without collateral
so the question is how does it function
when you put it into mammalian cells
so we actually used the
a very similar assay targeting
ratiometric luciferase reporter with a
gaussian luciferase and criprodine
luciferase
and we actually targeted those by
co-expressing a cast 7-eleven and a
crispr rna targeting gaussian
and we measured the zippers
and we didn't just measure luciferase in
that condition but we also compared it
to
the whole family of different cast 13s
as well as rnai and you can see that
compared to many of the cast 13s
cast 711 actually has
just as good or
better knocked down compared to cass13a
now
comparing this to our findings that cast
13s don't have collateral activity in
hex 293 ft cells
we saw that reproduced so
if you knock down this reporter
transcript you don't see any effect on
cell viability in hex293ft cells
however we wanted to check this against
multiple different cell types so if you
then compare
the knockdown efficiency in u87 cells
first we saw that casa11 still achieves
great talk down and rna actually does
not work in u87 sub cells which is a
known phenomenon
but if you look at the viability of
these cells
you actually see that we get a large
decrease in cell viability for the
targeting conditions with many of these
cast 13ps so you can see that in
comparing the targeting non-targeting
and often just expression of the casper
team itself you can have a large
decrease in cell viability compared to
the cast 7-elevens which saw a minimal
decrease in cell viability and no
difference between the targeting and
non-targeting cell liabilities so
there you see that there's a substantial
decrease in these activity in these uh
viabilities which is due to the large
penalty of the collateral
so with cast 711 we're adding yet
another protein in this arsenal that
allows us to have a large range of
applications so although we've just
talked about knockdown today you can
imagine that rna binding proteins enable
a huge swath of different potential
applications by being able to fuse
different proteins or domains to them we
can modulate translation and we can
affect exon skipping so we can modulate
splicing
we can alter a localization and we can
even affect the epi transcriptome which
actually some groups have shown with
cast 13.
so we think that cat 13 and now cast 711
represent a growing rna targeting crispr
toolbox so if you think about all the
different things we can do for dna
targeting
you know
crispr eye crisp array
base editing prime editing
there's a huge amount of things we can
do there on the bottom
and on the top now in the rna charging
toolbox we do have a wide and growing
range of applications
and these really come back to the
capacity to mine natural diversity for
biology and biotechnology so we kind of
want to leave people with this thought
of what else is in this tree of life
that will allow us to create new
molecular tools
and just to give you a preview of what
we're thinking of in our lab
we're thinking about of course tools for
precise rna modulation and we're
continuing to develop both cast 711 as
well as some cast 13 tools for expanding
that rna targeting toolbox we're also
very interested in the capacity to be
able to do efficient programmable gene
integration uh without relying on
endogenous repair machineries or
double-stranded breaks so being able to
actually put large pieces of dna into
the genome is something that we're very
excited about
both for its therapeutic as well as its
basic biology applications and
once again mining natural diversity
we think is a great way to get us there
so of course as part of this cell
engineering toolbox
we love the capacity to be able to
actually
measure rna states and use those to both
non-invasively
measure and see where cells are without
destroying them as well as using the
capacity for circuits to control these
cell states
and we're very excited about using
natural tools once again from these
natural enzymes to be able to enable
that so
it's something that we're very actively
working on so with that we'd like to
thank
the entire avide gutenberg lab um we're
actively looking for postdocs across
multiple of those pieces of the cell
engineering toolbox that we described
but here we are uh pre-covered enjoying
some sushi um and we're based at the
mcgovern institute you can find out more
at
abugoot.mit.edu
and we'd also like to thank the um
specific contributors to those stories
on a lot of the work for
the
top covid was in collaboration with the
jean group at the broad institute um and
the cast sermon discovery was in
collaboration with eugene kunin uh at
nih and uh it was led by hasan ozkan um
but we'd like to thank all the members
of the lab who made this possible
um and with that we'd like to open up to
any questions people might have